U.S officials now say that Chinese spy
balloon shot down off the Atlantic coast
nearly a week ago apparently was trying
to monitor nuclear command and control
Communications the Biden Administration
believes similar balloons may have flown
over as many as 40 other countries our
Nancy Cordis is at the White House this
morning Nancy what more do you know
David I know that some of the balloons
scaffolding and Equipment has now been
recovered but Heavy Seas are hampering
the recovery of the rest and so now the
Navy is taking steps to weigh that
debris down to keep it from drifting
away until they can scoop it up
FBI agents are now examining parts of
the Chinese balloon that have already
been fished out of the ocean oh look
they hit it the deflated balloon
descended rapidly Saturday from an
altitude twice as high as commercial jet
corridors but the so-called payload The
crucial surveillance equipment remains
on the sea floor off the South Carolina
coast the yeas are 419 the Nays are zero
the house voted unanimously Thursday to
condemn what it called China's Brazen
violation of United States sovereignty I
am so
angry lawmakers from both sides
expressed alarm at a senate hearing
about the incident I don't want a damn
balloon going across the United States
when we potentially could have taken it
down John tester is the Democratic
senator from Montana this is the test of
one of those missiles the Chinese were
apparently trying to listen in on the
communications used for the command and
control of nuclear weapons you guys have
to help me understand why this baby
wasn't taken out long before we think
before we shoot Pentagon officials said
they considered shooting it down over a
remote part of Alaska but were concerned
even then about casualties at that time
we didn't understand through the
modeling if we shot that what it would
do on the ground the state department
revealed Thursday that similar Chinese
spyballoons have flown over 40 countries
on five continents officials say the
Chinese military uses a fleet of high
altitude balloons as a cheap alternative
to satellites this irresponsible act put
on full display what we've long
recognized is the PRC has become more
repressive at home and more aggressive
abroad
investigators are looking into whether
this Chinese balloon was actually using
American made technology the White House
is now working on an executive order
that would put stronger export controls
in place to ensure that U.S technology
doesn't get into the hands of the
Chinese military Tony
well Nancy hindsight's always 20 20 but
you can understand the frustration of
those Senators there thank you very much
we'll stay on it